lo que ayer fue un símbolo de
agradecimiento hoy cada pedazos
Polonia derribó varios monumentos
dedicados a los Soldados del ejército
rojo que murieron en la Segunda Guerra
Mundial
Polonia es una nación libre
independiente no somos una colonia rusa
no somos parte del sistema Imperial ruso
como solía ser en los tiempos del
comunismo y este monumento que cae es la
mejor prueba de eso gente libre en un
mundo libre
los soviéticos no trajeron la libertad
del régimen nazi sino la esclavitud el
derribo es también una protesta a la
invasión rusa sobre Ucrania además de
los monumentos derribados en glupsia
también hubo demoliciones en bichina
morque y boboliche Rusia condenó el
hecho en voz del Dimitri y Scott
es otro intento de engañar y seguir
engañando a la generación más joven de
polacos alimentando los con mentiras y
provocando el odio hacia los rusos la
historia mostrará cuán incorrecta fue
esta decisión es imposible verlo de otra
manera
Este es un tema ampliamente debatido
entre Rusia y Polonia una parte de los
polacos creen que el gobierno impuesto
por la unión soviética reemplazó el
régimen nazi con otras formas de
opresión mientras que Moscú argumenta
que liberó Polonia cuando sus fuerzas
vencieron a las tropas de Hitler en ese
territorio